all I want you to ever do is try be the
changed everything with me just taking
action rise and shine it's an expresso
time what's up elimination it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your tea and sip
on today's message try over to you Mel
Robbins also if you want to know what
Mel Robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below everybody's
problem comes down to one pattern you're
repeating that you can't see your brain
helps you and if you're somebody that's
watching this and you have no clue what
you want I'm gonna say that's total bull
[Music]
if you had to pick one word that was you
one word that represented your essence
and so let me explain what I mean by
essence have you ever been around a dog
that gets wet and they shake and then
there gets all over you
that to me is the definition of essence
so you walk into a room what is it that
shakes off on to other people what's the
word right here excited anyone else
determined time energy back in the back
to shut up
thoughtful love sexy awesome so it was
interesting because the word that fell
out because I immediately thought oh I
wonder if mine is confidence and then I
thought well wait a minute actually no
it's try all I want you to ever do is
try that's it I just want you to try in
those moments where you hear yourself I
want you to try in those moments where
you know that it's time to speak up I
want you to
all the commitment stuff oh you got to
be committed all you got to be committed
we always talking to my trainer about
this you gotta be committed yep treat
this there's only one thing you really
have to do
it's a commitments not gonna come until
you do this other thing
the thing that has got me through
everything got me to where I'm at today
but they either changed everything was
me just taking action just doing it I
mean I know that said old Nike saying
right just do it and even if you don't
feel like it even if you're not
committed even if you're not getting any
gains even if you're not winning I
talked about this in the rules of
success show up just take action make
the call
knock on the door send out the email
blog people if you have to you know
until you get good and it doesn't sound
like bugging anymore it's just the
professional knows how to bug people
without bugging them so look just take
action even if you don't feel like it I
mean the only action you know if you if
you smoking drugs and doing drugs and
drinking all the time dude you need to
stop doing that so you can take action
in the right direction
you're gonna play big say big you're
gonna play huge say huge you're gonna
play ginormous say ginormous
but first take baby steps you gonna eat
the elephant but take one small bite
first chew it good right we want so much
so fast my grandmother says baby she
starts every sentence with baby I'm sure
it's because she cannot remember all of
our names she said baby the best things
you'll ever have from Grandma will never
come from the microwave they always come
from the oven and I was like I think
some somehow she's trying to give me a
lesson here and I realized that the best
things that you're gonna create are
gonna take time build it on cement not
sinking saying you're gonna get tons and
tons and tons of tools here and you're
gonna want to fast forward when you fast
forward you're building on Plexiglas
you're betting on star
phone you've been on would you want to
build it on semen your dream is
important enough to outlive you yes yes
and so I realized that that you can't
Google download resiliency you can't
Google download tenacity
you can't Google download forgiveness
there's some of the best qualities and
characteristics that's gonna take you a
long way that you need to invest time in
and energy in and intention in you don't
just get patience I want patience I'm
waiting for pick somebody's gonna piss
you off tomorrow and now you get to test
of your patience I realized I realized
that as I wanted to develop me I have to
be willing to climb and I wanted to get
to the top and there's no elevator to
the top I got to do my squats I got to
work on my quads and my hamstrings and
my calves cuz I gotta climb to the top
we got a climb raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that
passion not one drop of most self-worth
depends on Europe it's suppose to mean
if you liked this video one more Mel
Robbins check out the top 50 rules video
I made on her the link is right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there
if you are somebody that is sitting
around waiting for some external force
to come and do the work for you that is
such a closing bet it's unbelievable